un bus 30 mètres carrés avec ses espaces
définis et huit personnes pour
accompagner des femmes en situation
d'isolement c'est le projet qui tenait à
coeur à la directrice de l'institut des
hauts de seine un an et demi de
prospection et de réunion pour arriver
aujourd'hui à la création de ce premier
bus santé des femmes et j'avais vraiment
la volonté de le faire parce que ça
répond vraiment un manque un manque il
n'y a pas de structure pour accompagner
la solitude de la femme il ya des
structures pour le handicap des
structures pour la plage il ya des
structures pour la précarité
mais la solitude c'est une urgence
sociale qui n'est pas encore défini par
par nos hommes politiques et par nos
gouvernants deux cent mille euros
d'investissement réunis grâce à la
région ile de france les départements
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine et un
partenariat avec la ratp 72
interventions sont programmées en 2020
36 dans chaque département l'itinérance
c'est pour aller au plus près de ces
populations isolées
nous on a déjà testé l'itinérance dans
le département des yvelines avec un bus
pmi et ça fonctionne bien on va vers des
publics qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés pour quelques raisons que ce
soit à se déplacer des professionnels de
santé une coordinatrice pour assurer
l'accueil des femmes et du personnel
juridique l'ordre des avocats des
hauts-de-seine le barreau de versailles
et l'ordre des médecins du 92 ont
répondu présent pour ce projet une vraie
collaboration possible grâce à ce bus de
la ratp entièrement réhabilité on va
apporter aussi un soutien à la fois
logistiques puisqu'on prête le bus
et puis on met à disposition donc des
salariés pour permettre tout simplement
de conduire le bus des salariés
volontaires ils conduiront ce bus pour
une première dans les yvelines le 2
décembre à rambouillet et le 3 à
conflans sainte honorine